Nintendo has released the patch notes
for the upcoming scarlet and violet
update promising feature adjustments and
numerous bug fixes Pokemon scarlet and
violet version
1.2.0 still doesn't have a release date
more specific than the end of February
but Nintendo has released the patch
notes detailing what will be featured in
the update and noted that more are
planned for it in terms of feature
adjustments the main focus is on
additional functionality for the Pokemon
boxes when on a Pokemon summary you'll
now be able to change a given Pokemon's
nickname markings held items and Mark or
Ribbon related titles you'll also be
able to reorder moves have Pokemon
remember or forget moves and use TMs a
number of other changes are coming to
the Pokemon boxes too like being able to
select all boxes while moving Pokemon or
items in the party in boxes view
handheld items view the new screen will
also now be displayed once you're
connected to the internet many people
will be looking for bug fixes of which
there are new numerous in this update a
range of bug fixes are coming to Terror
raid battles including a bug that can
prevent opposing Terror Pokemon's HP
gauge properly reflecting the amount of
damage done another that stops you from
being able to make any kind of input if
a terror Pokemon makes certain actions
while you're choosing your Target and a
communication error bug that can display
a different Pokemon to you than what the
host sees pug fixes for battles are
mostly Pokemon specific like one where
if a Zoroark has cherastalized and is
disguised as another Pokemon using its
illusion ability the type matchups of
moves are displayed based on the type of
the Pokemon that Zoroark is disguised as
rather than zoroark's Terror type there
are more broad fixes coming like for one
bug where tight matchups against Pokemon
that have fainted won't show up when
choosing a move or Target during double
battles one bug in ranked battles season
1 saw players facing a communication
error right after they receive leave
this season's rewards if they visited
the ranked battle screen immediately
after The Season's results had been
calculated this error prevented players
from playing more ranked battles but
will be fixed in the next update another
bug stopped the Pokedex from displaying
additional entries like shiny Pokemon or
Pokemon received through a surprise
trade from players that play in a
different language if they were already
registered in the Pokedex but this too
will be fixed you also won't see random
pokeballs in places they shouldn't be
and passers-by won't appear on screen
During certain battles that take place
in towns during the main story there are
numerous other fixes coming too not all
of which are displayed in the patch
notes though there's no mention of
arguably the biggest issue the game
faces currently its choppy frame rate
you can read the full list of patch
notes over on gamespot.com remember eat
your veggies drink some water and have a
great weekend
thank you